and with grandmaster vision on - as he
said quadruple his score today I know
the last six months this word retirement
has been a thorn in your side are you
happy that for one week the word
retirement is only being discussed with
this far-off for once
yes its mace that that I'm now the
second oldest participant by a wide
margin so which has not been the case
through very long time yeah I mean I
don't know why I played so badly
yesterday but I'm happy that today at
least some semblance of control returned
and that's good stock
he said he arrived with an unfriendly
face but that surprised you after all
you've got a longer rapport with him and
any other player nobody I mean some
people smile and thing appear I do well
it was like old times I mean I wouldn't
say too much about it but it's like old
times and and it was a nice game I mean
I tried to play a scheme that he might
not have been that family it was but
well he may have held on pretty well so
and then it was nice day in fact it's
the chatting I'd missed so we sat and
discussed the game for 19 5-10 minutes
and he was complaining with his other
misses and so on nice so it almost would
have been out of place he could come to
the board with a smile because that's
not the Gary you know like I said I
wouldn't make too much out of it I mean
he gave me a sort of nah I think
probably unfriendly is strong what he
did was kind of this you know this is
serious we're not we're not having fun
I'm not having fun yeah but nonetheless
well all the old how the old stuff back
you enjoyed the chatting with him any
chance you're going to hang out socially
with him here in st. Louis I think the
very good chance we will do that I mean
I don't know if we go tonight or
something but definitely there'll be
some formal dinners when and already
last year during the champion showdown
the four of us
Gary joined us on a couple occasions
so that Celine me and Gary and Rex we
all went out for dinner and I remember
we had some enjoyable chats that and the
video going to dealing with Rex is that
you're the third oldest if Gary's
joining so you've got that going for you
well I know that you're not going to
join Gary when you've got two games
remaining but I think you made a lot of
people happy by seeing the old guard
play some good chess today so we wish
you good luck on forward okay thanks a
lot